lutter contre l'évasion fiscale et
contraindre les grandes fortunes à payer
leurs impôts en france était l'un des
objectifs affichés par emmanuel macron
au début de son quinquennat
nous sommes en décembre 2018 le
mouvement et gilet jaune et la
contestation populaire prennent une
ampleur inédite
le chef de l'état prend alors la parole
le gouvernement et le parlement devront
aller plus loin pour mettre fin aux
avantages indus et aux évasions fiscales
le dirigeant d'une entreprise française
doit payer ses impôts en france et les
grandes entreprises qui font du profit
doivent-ils payer l'impôt c'est la
simple justice
vous le voyez nous répondrons à
l'urgence économique et social par des
mesures fortes par des baisses d'impôts
plus rapide par une meilleure maîtrise
des dépenses plutôt que par des reculs
deux ans et demi plus tard ces paroles
semblent lointaines et peuvent même
s'apparenter à de la poudre de
perlimpinpin
comme l'avait dit ce même emmanuel
macron pendant sa campagne
la raison une nouvelle directive
européenne sur les obligations de
transparence des entreprises
elle défend le principe d'une
comptabilité pays par pays à des
entreprises pour éviter à l'optimisation
fiscale au profit d'états ou
l'imposition des bénéfices est plus
avantageuse
en clair lutter contre l'évasion fiscale
pour défendre le projet à bruxelles
chaque pays membre de l'union européenne
a donc transmis un document de position
censée être le plus objectif possible
sauf qu'en france ce fameux document
était rédigée en partie par le mouvement
des entreprises de france selon le média
contexte autrement dit par le medef donc
le patronat français niveau objectivité
sur la transparence fiscale du coup
c'est un peu léger voire inconsistant
pour plusieurs ong
c'est tout bonnement scandaleux c'est
tout simplement choquant et très
inquiétant officiellement soutien de la
mesure l'attitude de la france était de
plus en plus ambiguë dans les
négociations de cette directive
cherchant à amoindrir le texte quitte à
le rendre inopérant
on comprend maintenant qu'elle a
construit sa stratégie en lien avec des
grands groupes
c'est incompréhensible que la france se
fasse leur porte parole
plutôt que de défendre
mesures efficaces contre l'évasion
fiscale côté politique les réactions ne
se sont pas fait attendre et c'est un
sentiment d'indignation qui a été
exprimée du côté est de la gauche et des
verts
pour pascal canfin président de la
commission environnement au parlement
européen c'est inacceptable
l eurodéputé à claude gruffat accuse lui
emmanuel macron d'être le président des
lobbys et non de l'intérêt général tout
comme l'ancien l'eurodéputée eva joly
qui à travers un message vidéo posté sur
twitter elle interpelle le chef de
l'état même son cloche du côté de la
france insoumise avec mano aubry qui
dénoncent l' influence des lobbys à
bruxelles
je me demande si en face de moi dans les
négociations à ce que je vais discuter
avec les représentants de la france et
du conseil
ou est-ce que je vais discuter avec les
représentants du medef ce qui illustre
le poids nocifs des lobbys sur ces
négociations et c'est pour ça qu'on va
avoir besoin de vous pour dénoncer ce
scandale et pour dire que nous toutes et
nous tous on a besoin de la transparence
fiscale des multinationales
on a besoin de savoir si elles payent
leur juste part d'impôts et il est
scandaleux que ces grandes entreprises
ces géants ne payent pas leur juste part
d'impôts quand nous tous à nous on n'a
pas toutes les petites entreprises n'ont
pas de filiales dans les paradis fiscaux
du côté de bercy on regrette la
confusion qui a pu engendrer
l'utilisation d'un document créé au
départ par le medef mais on assure que
le document a été profondément remanié
par les équipes du ministère des
finances
quoi qu'il en soit la démarche de base
est tout de même représentative d'un
certain parti pris de l'exécutif
loin d'être transparent s'agissant
l'évasion fiscale